Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans le Coup de Phil'.
L'autre jour je pensais à l'état de nature,
(c'est la situation dans laquelle on se serait trouvé avant l'émergence de la société)
et je me demandais à quoi ça pouvait ressembler ?
*Cris de bagarre primitifs*
Et en fait ça aurait été vraiment pourri voire juste impossible,
tout simplement parce qu'il nous faut des règles.
Ok pour les règles...
Mais pas plus d'une fois par mois.
Mais avec les règles, est-ce qu'on perd pas un petit peu de notre liberté naturelle ?
Beh si !
Du coup, il nous faut une nouvelle liberté.
Et ça c'est Rousseau qui nous le dit dans Le Contrat Social...
... de Rousseau !
Rousseau donc, philosophe des lumières qui a écr...
Oh ! Ffff !
Génial les gars. Super, super la blague. Génial.
Bref, Rousseau il a écrit : "Du Contrat Social",
et dans ce livre il réfléchit à comment imposer d'une manière légitime une autorité à un peuple ?
Mais est-ce que c'est pas une fausse question ?
Ah j'avoue ! Ah j'avoue les gars, c'est une fausse question en fait !
Genre Rousseau c'est un batard, il nous embrouille et tout. C'est ouf.
Pourquoi c'est une fausse question en fait ? Ça j'ai pas compris...
Parce que Rousseau se rend compte que le peuple n'existe pas sans autorité.
Sinon ça ne serait qu'un simple regroupement d'individus, et non un peuple.
Donc si le peuple n'existe pas sans autorité, ça veut dire que dès qu'on parle de peuple, il y a autorité.
Et donc c'est l'autorité qui permet au peuple d'exister.
Donc, on sort d'une opposition entre peuple et autorité.
Eh ouais mon gars ! Eh ouais !
Merci de m'avoir choisi, de m'avoir élu.
Et j'exercerai mon autorité avec le plus de loyauté possible.
Merci, et vive nous !
*pet*
Pourquoi ça ne marche pas ?
Euh, juste, excuse moi, en fait là ça ne marche pas parce que tu n'as pas de peuple en fait.
Ah ça c'est, ça c'est bon à savoir. Ah ça voilà, ouais, ça personne ne me le dit.
Pour comprendre d'où viennent ce peuple et cette autorité, il faut retourner à l'état de nature.
A l'état de nature les hommes s'embrouillent et donc ils doivent s'associer pour survivre.
Ok pour trouver une forme d'association qui nous permette de vivre en société.
Pas de souci.
Mais cette forme, on doit s'y sentir libre, et doit y être protégé.
Oui parce qu’à priori ça ne va pas toujours ensemble.
Je peux te mettre dans une cage, tu y seras super protégé mais tu seras pas libre du tout.
Et à l'inverse tu peux avoir toute la liberté du monde et tu ne vas pas tenir 5 minutes.
D'ailleurs, il y en a un qui a quitté le contrat social (c'est le mec d'"Into the Wild") et on a vu ce que ça a donné.
Le mec a fini par se geler les coucougnettes, dans un van, au fin fond de l'Alaska.
*Gémissements et pleurs*
Alors que dans le contrat t'es libre et protégé.
Et c'est pour ça que le contrat est double.
Je m'engage moi-même envers la société et par conséquent je me place sous son autorité.
Et en échange, la société s'engage envers moi et m'offre plus de liberté et plus de sécurité.
Elle est pas belle la vie ?
Deux ans après avoir signé son contrat social, Jean-Marcel se sent trahi.
Donc la société n'a pas respecté ses engagements ?
Non ! Non ! La société n'a respecté aucun engagement qu'elle a avec moi, notamment celui de la propriété !
En gros, ma propriété doit être protégée par la société.
Si quelqu'un voulait venir me prendre un bien, la soc...
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? *tape*
Elle est où la société ?
Où est la sociét...
C'est pour ça que le lien entre souverain et peuple est réciproque et double.
Chaque individu devient citoyen et participe à l'autorité souveraine en votant, par exemple,
et en même temps il est sujet, car il est soumis aux lois.
Excusez-moi... Est-ce que c'est ici la soirée soumission ?
Enfin dans la démocratie en tout cas. Pas dans les régimes qui utilisent la force.
Et ça c'est très lié au fait que l'expression "Le droit du plus fort", bah ça n'a pas de sens, tu vois ?
C'est un oxymore.
C'est comme "mort-vivant", "clair-obscur", "réalité virtuelle".
Bah oui ! Le droit ça appartient à la morale, tu le suis volontairement, alors que la force pas du tout !
Et c'est pour ça que tu n'as pas ce sentiment de citoyenneté quand tu obéis à la force.
Clique ici pour une vidéo bonus sur les conditions à respecter pour entrer dans le contrat social.
Au fait, j'ai pas réussi à le caser correctement mais, je voulais juste vous dire que pour Rousseau,
la première société, c'est la famille. Donc soyez gentils avec vos mamans !
Et si vous aussi vous avez l'impression que parfois on se fout de notre gueule dans le contrat social actuel,
n'hésitez pas à dire ce que vous pensez dans les commentaires.
En tout cas j'espère que le contrat social est maintenant plus clair pour toi,
et n'oublie pas, de la même façon que sans peuple il n'y a pas d'autorité,
sans toi, il n'y a pas de Coup de Phil'.
En attendant, on se retrouve pour un prochain épisode du Coup de Phil'.
D'ici là, du love et de la peace.
Yalla !
Et du fin fond de l'Ontario, je vous présente, Jean-Jacques Ruisseau !